hello youtubers right maybe bump on the
set you up do something I love that
Google question statement mashup that I
just joined this those are awesome ideas
and they should all be done or not they
should all be done by people here it's
kind of crazy people who are here they
can also be done by you there's no
reason why enough to wait to read any of
those ideas that you just mentioned you
have the power now to make it happen
some of those ideas don't even require
much money so to start acting and make a
difference now while you're still young
and idealistic and passionate before you
become old like a lot of the people here
okay that's all right